[Music]
facts in the post-truth era
um well facts are just fine we don't
have to worry about them
they're there whether we like it or not
but we do have to worry about us and our
relationship with facts and that's what
i'm going to be
talking about so this was the word of
the year 2017
post truth um but it's not completely
clear what it might mean truth is there
of course still
what is it that's posed here's how it's
defined
it's the idea that objective facts are
less influential in shaping public
opinion
than emotions and personal
it's not a very good definition as we
shall see
but you get the general idea that
somehow
we are not believing in accordance with
how the world is but in accordance with
our emotions and all sorts of
uh general uh personal belief and of
course
this has its manifestations we know
about a few of those we have the fake
news
right after the big fire at the notre
dame cathedral
the fire wasn't out before the fake news
was out
um here were three of them that the
islamist extremists called the fire
that the mosque would be built
afterwards and even that uh
vladimir zelinski you know the he was
then the candidate to be president in
the ukraine
he had set the fire so it's very
creative
we have also of course uh conspiracy
theories are being
uh spread more than ever um
and this of course is the theory that we
never went to the moon that it was all a
conspiracy
um when i looked last i think eleven
percent of the u.s population believes
in that but it's not just the american
sweeps i think about six percent i'm a
from sweden
um and of course we even have the flat
earth society having a boom
right now that one can giggle out but
it's not so funny when one thinks about
some of
the other manifestations of this such as
climate denial
people often ask me is there more
knowledge resistance now than before we
don't have numbers on that
but we do know that certain types of
science denial is getting a lot of
spread
such as climate denial and of course
some of the climate deniers have a lot
of power
they are president so um
and then there is of course this which
is the anti-vaxxers
um the world health organization listed
uh
vaccine testing or vaccine
denial as one of the top 10 threats to
world health 2019
it's not just measles we've heard a lot
about mises in europe and the us because
it's spreading like crazy
during the 2017 it had a 300 increase
it continued like that during 2018 and
now it's double the speed
but it's also other vaccines so it's
pretty serious stuff
and then we have this which is uh by
don cayenne a political scientist being
called fact polarization
people poll our eyes according to
political views that's okay we have
different values
but now we have a situation where
depending on
which political group we belong to we
believe in different facts
and the other group and that's what he
calls fact polarization
and he suggests that people who used to
be divided over the relative weight of
liberty and equality are less sharply
divided today over the justice or
progressive taxation the classical kind
of political value issue
then over the evidence that human carbon
dioxide emissions are driving up global
temperatures
so that's a really strange situation so
what i want to do today is try to
provide some tools for understanding
what's going on i think it's a very
complex situation
but i think there are at least three
components in this that one has to
understand
and uh so before the break up until the
break i would sort of talk about what's
setting this up
and then after the break i hope to get a
little more kind of constructive
but i i want to say at the outset it's a
very complex problem
and no one should think oh well i will
talk about that a little bit of critical
thinking will solve it no i won't
so here's my plan i will talk a little
bit first about what i call epistemic
vulnerabilities
reasons why the sort of nature of
knowledge itself makes
us vulnerable and then i want to talk
about our psychological vulnerabilities
and then of course how this interacts
with the new technology and the
disinformation situation we're in
because it is this interaction between
these three components
this sounds maybe strange epistemic
vulnerabilities but i think there
are such sometimes it said i mean i just
want to
put one thing to the side because
there's one type of debate where
people without science do it because
they don't trust the scientific method
they don't believe in the scientific
method
i think there are other ways of getting
knowledge through
you know faith or
intuition or something like that and and
michael lynch
american philosophers talked a lot about
post-truth he talks about this a lot and
he's quite right to point out that this
of course is a very big problem if
people don't believe in scientific
method
then what do you do how do you sort of
bootstrap yourself and argue for the
scientific method
i'm going to put that problem to the
side because i don't think it's central
to
this i think it's central to other
things like craziness in the u.s and so
on
but i think here we have something else
going on because indeed
much of science denial is driven by the
scientific
sort of attitudes people are being want
to be very scientific
they really want to find truth and then
they go about it in this strange way
here's a nice example after the notre
dame fire
uh people were spreading this hoax that
the muslims set set
the whole thing on fire um and to prove
that
they were doing these experiments where
they were trying to put fire to oak
by using this flame sort of uh for ours
right
and they were proving showing that it's
really really hard to do this
so it couldn't possibly be that the fire
started by itself
that's a very scientific attitude right
we'll get back to whether it does why
it's not a good argument
but it's it's not unscientific so this
was being spread on facebook
so what is it about the nature of
knowledge that makes this so
hard i want to make a couple of points
here and i'm going to do it by using the
traditional philosophical definition of
knowledge
most of you may have heard it it's
ancient it goes back to plato
it's pretty much the starting point for
contemporary philosophy even though
people
sort of discuss the details in
particular they discuss whether these
three conditions are sufficient
but let's not worry about that because
they're necessary and that's all we need
to make the points i want to make today
so to know something to know that earth
is round
you have to at least believe it if you
don't do that you have no knowledge so
the flat earthers don't know it
but you can't just believe it because
you could believe
something very strongly that's false and
you don't have knowledge so it has to be
true
but that's not enough i then already
plato pointed that out because here's
your belief
it has to be true somehow connected with
reality but that's not enough there has
to be some relationship between you
and the truth that is to say it has to
be not just a lucky guess
you need some kind of evidence grounds
reasons
for your belief for it to be knowledge
and it's when it comes
to this third point that things get
tricky
with knowledge resistance and i'll spell
that out in a second
let me just say one thing about truth
it's a property
of what we say or what we believe so if
i say the earth is flat
this statement has it or it doesn't have
it
there are lots of philosophical theories
about truth that i won't talk about this
what i consider serious theories
take truth to be objective in this sense
that
whether or not what i say has this
property is not determined
by what i think about the matter if i
think it's true doesn't make it true
well if all of you think it's true that
doesn't make it true if the entire world
thinks it's true
that doesn't make it true so this is
this potential
gap between our beliefs and truth and
that we just have to live with
now sometimes people get angry at me
when i say the truth is objective
because they say
how very dogmatic of you you're so
dogmatic
and then i say no it's the other way
around it's precisely because
truth is objective that we have to be
undogmatic
and humble because it shows it means
that we may be wrong it's very easy to
be wrong precisely because this property
truth is not up to us
we may be wrong that means i should
listen to objections i should be open to
the possibility
that i'm wrong and listen to other
people if truth were subjective there
would be no reason for me to listen to
other people
that's just the point i want to make
now evidence i said that what gets us
into trouble is evidence so let me say a
few things about that
now if you think about how do you know
that you're sitting here listening to
some swede talking about knowledge
resistance
well you sort of see it hear it you read
it in the program
you experience it most of the things we
know in our daily life who may sort of
uh get around in the world of course
comes from our experiences
from what we see and feel and hear and
so on
that's very important source on
knowledge and we have that in common
with the animals
that's how we orient ourselves in the
world however we also have another very
important source of knowledge
unlike the animals other people who know
more and this is what philosophers call
testimonial knowledge because it comes
from
linguistic testimony i can find out
about the world
by going to other people going to
sources and getting knowledge that way
this is an amazing thing about human
beings we have this division of
cognitive labor
each of us collect knowledge through our
lives that we then can spread through
language to other individuals
that then is spread from generation to
generation we have a knowledge
accumulation
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you